all right 8 news now is partnering with
the american red cross today for the
annual day of giving
and that includes a huge blood drive
taking place later on hector mejia is
live at the red cross headquarters with
a look at how you can help hector good
afternoon good morning
good afternoon good afternoon and good
afternoon and good morning hey there
how's it going so
it's a very special day for us here as
we team up with the american red cross
and we're sort of getting a
behind-the-scenes look here
so this is a wall of supplies this is
what's needed when uh
they draw some blood and there is a need
not only every single day but in fact
every two seconds someone is in need of
blood and it's life-saving
joining us live we have alan disc in
here executive director
at the american red cross of southern
nevada good morning to you sir good
morning thanks for having us
thanks for having us and so we have this
blood drive happening today at 11 30 at
sahara west library but right now
what are we picking up so these are all
the supplies we'll use today
to draw blood inside here are all the
supplies that people need
to physically give and donate blood and
then when we're done
we take that blood we put it back in
these containers we ship it to be tran
to be tested and transported processed
and brought back to those that need it
as you can see
the need is constant the gratification
is instant we're always encouraging
people to give blood
alan on that note i remember during you
know months months ago during the thick
of the pandemic
the red cross talking about a shortage
is there still a shortage right now
there's always a need for blood and
today is no different
every day somebody needs blood for
trauma
for cancer for sickle cell so we say the
need is constant it's
always in demand and we want people to
not only give but give regularly so that
we can maintain a constant blood supply
and it's also important to note you were
saying
not a lot of people know this but also
when you donate blood
uh you can potentially help out someone
who is recovering from covet 19 is that
correct
yeah so like myself i contracted covered
19
in during the holiday months i ended up
in the hospital and i remember them
saying we're waiting for one of those
treatments
it should be here soon it's uh it's
delayed and
not until it walked into the room did i
realize it was convalescent plasma
something near and dear to my heart so
when you donate blood
we can use that blood we can separate
your plasma if you have
cova-19 antibodies and that can be used
for the sickest of patients
and if you don't have the antibodies we
can still use that blood
for patients that need it for cancer or
other treatments awesome thank you for
having us so we're going to pack up
again details about the blood drive
sahara west library that is by grand
canyon
and sahara starting at 11 30 this
morning keep in mind though because of
social distancing
you will need an appointment we have all
of that information already posted
online
you can check out eightnewsnow.com for
all of the details for now reporting
live hector mejia 8 news now back to you
guys
hector thank you very much it is
certainly very important mate and i will
be out there
this afternoon at the blood drive so
we'll have the coverage of giving day
all day long thank you hector